it's just mind-blowing when i think
about
the [ __ ] that people jamario jamario
told me i'm saying people don't even
remember
a lot of people don't remember who
jamario dramario is but he's the be
the big atlanta comic he was a huge
atlanta comic
you look if you go back and look up
jamario jamario jamario mario was funny
as [ __ ] man
jamario told me saying man again
you don't realize when you become a
headliner the type of pressure
that it has this on the headline and
[ __ ] it's a lot of pressure on the
headliner you know people don't realize
that
a lot of other things you're dealing
with god damn in the headline is rough
no [ __ ] and then people don't
realize that
you open and you feature and you get
spotting all that [ __ ] don't mean a
[ __ ] thing
headline is a whole different monster
not closing the show not going last
but you [ __ ] headline cause you
got a lot of [ __ ] to deal with a lot of
comedy come in front of you
yeah i'm saying and a lot of [ __ ] is on
you
see a feature ain't no pressure
appreciate no [ __ ] right
[ __ ] don't nobody expect you to do a
goddamn thing
you're just going out there you ain't
got to sell no tickets you ain't no you
ain't nobody
they ain't nobody it's just a lot man
and then
even as a even doing that you have to
deal with
an unknown uh unknown hiccup that's
going to come on your ass that you not
used to you've been doing stand up
20 years sometimes 25 years sometimes
15 and now you headline it and don't
realize
a check dropper [ __ ] your whole setup
because you thinking you rolling then
they come drop them checks and ain't
nobody listening to your ass no more you
think you losing them nah they on they
checks
they got to drop they check then they
gotta get back to you after that you
like god damn my shows i get that
[ __ ] just fell out to the bottom
and then i ain't never come out of the
hole cuz you thought you lost them
unseen hand the vicious check drop
yeah legendary that's coming yeah that's
[ __ ] coming
and me being a feature long enough
looking at hey lana's think they
bombing then i'm like hey
give me your tip i know you've been
doing a stand up 30 years but let me get
you
like a lightweight tip why don't you get
them to signal you
if they about to drop checks like i do
i just get a double like huh i'll say
well
i'll just ask that i said when y'all
dropping the checks
and he said well we use dropping checks
about
45 you know like 25 to 30 minutes in at
the headliner
that's how we know how much time see
people a lot of congress don't want to
learn the business enough they back in
the green room doing
whatever the [ __ ] they doing and [ __ ]
and not
putting a show together it's still some
most [ __ ] you got to do once you become
a headliner
you still got more [ __ ] you got to do so
you tell the person hey when y'all
getting ready to drop the checks
y'all do like that give me a double
light let me
let me know all the checks bout to drop
so let me not go into no intricate [ __ ]
or no real long story another let me
just a bunch of quick pop [ __ ]
because i know they're about to go on
checks okay or they can't do that we'll
do this for me
drop the back first
so then i have the front then drop the
front
then i had it back i don't need the
whole room
away from me at one time i'm saying yeah
just [ __ ] that you gotta put in place
for your show to be successful
i've never heard that before that's gold
and if anybody ever say they ever
thought they did a [ __ ] lie i
was the first comic
because i know i know other other older
comics that never thought of [ __ ] they
was like yo that [ __ ] genius
with that [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] genius with that because i
need you to know
because a comedy has to know we all in
this [ __ ] together
so i can't have you just like with a
wait staff
i want to wait staff as low as possible
i don't want you standing up in the
middle of my [ __ ] show because the
people behind you can't see
i shouldn't have to come in and groom a
weight stab but the comedy clubs
are not [ __ ] focused on what comedy
should be because you so busy trying to
just make some money
let me get the [ __ ] sensation in here
but [ __ ] get your [ __ ] weight staff
together
and the shows can be a lot more
consistent have some continuity to them
so how do you share this info with them
oh they're like a meeting tell them yeah
i tell them straight up hey man i don't
want the wait staff standing straight up
okay take
orders from here because that's how it's
done at my home club at the improv
i never [ __ ] see the wait staff at
the improv
i don't have to have no meeting with
them because they train right
they train right they they are [ __ ]
amazing staff
i nev they like ghosts in the room i
never see them they not blocking
consumers way trying to give some
consumers something else even when they
serving food
they come somebody come put the thing
down and they get the [ __ ] out the way
and then you come and you put the tray
down and you serve the food low
they they get out the way they don't try
to distract
anything from what's going on on the
stage because that's what's important
just like this is important mm-hmm